this is a talk called the tale to a
sinks or because I love incredibly long
titles how language values shape the
features we build and the journeys we
take to design them
this sucks probably gonna end up taking
the whole time because as you can see I
have a hundred and sixty six slides but
I know there is the app where you can
ask questions but this is also on github
and I am a good open-source maintainer
and if you ask questions and issues I
will follow up with you so by way of
introduction my name is Ashley Williams
or as you may know me from the internet
a g-dubs if you follow me on Twitter I'm
sorry
follow who at your own risk and I've
done a lot of things in my career for
the past two years though thankfully
kind of no longer I was on the node.js
board of directors and while I was doing
that I worked at this small company
called NPM that if you write any sort of
JavaScript you've probably heard of
while I was doing that I ran a inclusive
education program called node together
which focus on getting underrepresented
folks into programming by teaching them
node and education is my passion which
is something that's going to come up in
this talk I have worked on tc39 as
invited expert bringing educational
perspectives to the design of the
language but recently at the beginning
of the year I changed my job over and I
work for a company called Mozilla and I
work on a programming language called
rust which I did not expect to be so
featured in the keynote how many people
here write rust how many people would
like to try alright there we go that's
awesome so there's a whole bunch of
things here that I do open-source is
kind of like a startup there's lots to
do and you wear many hats but another
thing that came up in the keynote which
is amazing is currently I'm spending the
vast majority of my time building dev
tools for compiling rust into web
assembly and so that's what I spend most
of my time doing but when I got into
rust I started by being a teacher for
this program called rust bridge which is
a similar inclusive education
programmers know together getting
underrepresented folks into tech by
teaching them rust and so these are just
a couple of these pictures here of rust
bridge hat
and this is the kind of stuff that truly
inspires me about programming languages
in general sometimes I'll dress up like
a crab to teach so I love teaching
programming and it's because I really
love programming languages and
fundamentally I'm the type of person who
loves to think about thinking
particularly the type of thinking that
happens when people write code my degree
is not in computer science my degree is
in philosophy and neuroscience so you
can imagine where that thinking about
thinking comes in I went in for film and
then leaned in real hard into how-do
brains and Here I am today talking to
you about programming languages so the
goal of this talk today is to explore
two languages that I love and you can
see here that I rate nodejs and maybe
some of the patents in here might be
that's not a language yeah I get it I
know I'm up here on the stage I know
that it's a runtime but my familiarity
with JavaScript is primarily through
node and so I'm gonna talk a lot about
node but it will also talk a little bit
about JavaScript so this wouldn't be a
proper Ashley Williams talk if you've
ever seen me before if I didn't give you
a little bit of philosophy so let's get
right into it so one of my favorite
concepts in philosophy is this idea of
genealogy which is a historical
technique which is primarily looking at
how concepts emerge from the historical
context that they exist in and so here's
my lovely bushy mustache friend
Friedrich Nietzsche and one of the
things that he says is that a genealogy
often attempts to look beyond to the
discourse into the question of the
conditions of possibility what are the
things that made it so that this type of
conversation could emerge at this point
in time and so another fellow who was
incredibly interested in this topic was
this gentleman here Michel Foucault and
so he says this he says the point of a
genealogical analysis is to show that a
given system of thought was the result
of contingent turns of history not the
outcome of rationally inevitable trends
we were going to circle back to this so
do keep it in mind now I was making this
talk and I tweeted about it and one of
my friend said that is the nerdiest way
to say [ __ ] happens I've ever seen she's
not wrong but the thing that I'm really
excited about what genealogy is that
it's an investigation into elements
which we tend to feel are without
history and programming languages fit
this well programming languages are
deeply complex historical artifacts and
agents yet we rarely think of them as
such and so while I'm gonna be talking
about asynchronous features I'll be
talking about no JavaScript and rust
fundamentally what I want to talk about
is how we can view these things has
historical artifacts so another one of
my favorite favorite authors and if
you've ever ever looking for a book the
structure of scientific revolutions by
Thomas Kuhn really completely changed
the way I think and in that book he says
scientists worked for models acquired
through education and literature often
without quite knowing or needing to know
what characteristics have given these
models the status of community paradigms
and so here we need to question like we
do so many things but but why where what
are the origins of these things and that
was a question that throughout
university I was obsessed with in my
philosophy classes what are the origins
and so a great origin question is
particularly as a teacher is asked this
question what is the best first
programming language and if you google
this question you'll find a white paper
and it has this fantastically obtuse
diagram clearly you can tell what the
best programming languages from this but
this is a question that will also come
back to so inevitably would ask what is
the best anything it's a trap
and even though we know it's a trap we
often are happy to argue at length about
this kind of thing and one of the words
that we tend to say when we argue about
this is this idea of the best tool for
the job how many people have found
themselves saying best tool for the job
all right
I feel like people not raising their
hand are just not participating because
this is just something that happens all
the time and when we ask about what is
the best tool for the job we have to
start asking what do tools want to do
and so the question I'm here to really
ask today is what do programming
languages want and this is a question I
don't think we asked ourselves nearly as
much as we should so when I was
investigating this probably around three
years back I came across this idea of
programming language paradigms and so a
programming paradigm is an approach to
programming a computer based on
mathematical theory or a set of coherent
principles each paradigm supports a set
of concepts that makes it best for a
certain kind of problem so when we talk
about best tool for the job well we
start looking at is this idea of
paradigms so I love this because it was
a delightful computer scientist named
Peter van Roy who's clearly a very
serious individual and he's written
extensively about programming paradigms
and he was really some of my
foundational Cs learning reading all of
his papers and so he came up with this
idea of the paradigm paradox which is a
paradox to even attempt to pronounce but
it's the idea that more is not better or
worse than less just different and so
when we're looking at tools the best
tools for the job all right how do we
have programs or tools that solve
problems and are the tools that solve
more problems better or are they worse
and here he says no they're actually
equivalent there's a very interesting
play between those ideas and so he has
made another fantastic diagram I guess
computer scientists love making like
completely inscrutable diagrams but at
least this one's rainbows so we have
that and in this diagram he attempts to
map out a ton of programming languages
and the types of paradigms they fit in
or perhaps the multiple paradigms they
tend to fit and so when we're thinking
about genealogy addressing the types of
paradigms that programming languages
fill and then looking at that in a
historical context is a way we can start
approaching an idea of a genealogy of
programming languages so to get a little
bit more concrete at this point I like
to ask the question
type of tool or language I love calling
languages tools because it's so easy to
forget that that's really all they are
what type of tool does nodejs want to be
and so we're lucky here because there's
actually a little bit of design work
that actually happened and that you can
go and find a lot of the research done
about what types of tools languages want
to be is incredibly difficult to find
now unfortunately the thing that's
frustrating about trying to figure out
what does know'd want to be is that you
have to go back pretty far so this is
Ryan Dahl the creator of node when he is
originally oh yeah those the captions
are there for your pleasure so he
announced node in 2012
oh no 2009 but then this was republished
in 2012 and the goal of node was that he
fundamentally believed that the way we
were thinking about IO was not only
wrong but was making things incredibly
difficult and so just to step back and
think about it for a second a lot of us
are programmers here in the room and
there's this idea of asynchronous
programming and it's something that
feels kind of ubiquitous but
asynchronous programming is defined as
the idea of making it possible to
express waiting for long-running actions
without freezing the program during
these actions and I like putting this
out only because this is a quote from
Orion haver Beeks the eloquent
JavaScript and interestingly enough my
Ryan actually worked on the original
rust way way way back in the day our
computer science worlds are so so small
but with all of the works that we're
doing in asynchronous programming
regarding syntax it's able to express it
I think we often forget that really all
asynchronous programming is about is
this is the idea that what is the
software doing while it queries the
database and in this situation the
answer is nothing and asynchronous
programming goes well that's a big
problem alright we need to change that
and so fundamentally what we're doing is
we program asynchronous features is
really just handling this one very small
core concept and it seems small now but
this actually was an incredible problem
how many people here know what the C 10
keh problem is alright so I won't go
through and read this all but the idea
is that it turned out that sometimes and
before hacker news and stuff like this
there's this website called slash dot
and sometimes people's blog posts ended
up on it and they got so popular that
they would just completely crash the
servers that they were on you couldn't
visit them anymore because our
asynchronous story our concurrency story
was absolutely terrible so we would say
things like it's time for web servers to
handle 10,000 climat simultaneously
don't you think wow yeah after all the
web is a big place right now it's only
gotten so much larger and so not too
long ago this was published in 1999 it's
not too long ago that this was actually
an incredibly serious problem and so we
started coming up with ways to solve
this problem and the first problems are
the first solution we came up with was
this idea of threads which is
demonstrated incredibly scientifically
right here and so Ryan's all was
incredibly frustrated with this solution
and here he says threaded concurrency is
a leaky abstraction it creates pains you
have memory problems it's hard to think
about it it is not a good abstraction
for what is happening on your computer
and this is why he thought this it's
interesting to think all right so the
whole goal of node was like oh my gosh I
Oh needs to be asynchronous IO needs to
be a first-class citizen in this
language in fact it was the driving
design decision and so it's because at
the time what we were dealing with we
were thinking about server-side
technologies and concurrency was using
nginx and Apache
and so like many benchmarks the the
paper that gives this lovely graph like
I don't know dubious at best but
fundamentally what this describes is
that nginx and Apache can both support a
whole bunch of concurrent connections
and that's awesome but there was a bit
of a problem which is that as the
concurrent connections grow so who did
the memory usage and this is where we
ended up when we were having all sorts
of problems with the slash dot and the
blog post becoming incredibly popular
so this
state of asynchronous i/o as node was
emerging was bad he even talks a bit
about Ruby and like ruby was attempting
to do this with a vent machine and stuff
but even then that existed in the
ecosystem and there was many different
solutions and then trying to get the
ecosystem to play well together was
incredibly difficult so no it emerged as
we want one solution and we wanted to be
the primary design value and so this is
because threads are expensive and it was
like I don't want threads to be the
design solution and so with that came
node and node is based on this pattern
called the reactor pattern and so I did
some research and this is the original
diagram from the paper and you might be
more familiar with this pattern because
of this lovely thing called libuv how
many people here know about this unicorn
dinosaur it's a cool logo I'm glad we
have animal logos in tech but
fundamentally what this is is the nodejs
event loop and i think that this is
really interesting because fundamentally
a lot of people don't understand that
the event loop is actually a single
threaded scripting language for still
fundamentally a multi-threaded system
but it was adding this abstraction that
made it significantly easier for folks
to reason about and be able to express
programs and so in his in his talk and
he does regret this at this point he
goes callbacks is how IO should work and
if you follow any sort of noter
JavaScript technologies today you'll
know that callbacks might have been at
least maybe a little bit of a mistake
and we've definitely developed our our
things before that but fundamentally
this idea of callbacks was really the
design decision of node and this was
really great because node was really
trying to get JavaScript onto the server
and so JavaScript was designed
specifically to be used with an event
loop and the culture of JavaScript was
already geared towards evented
programming and so to kind of circle up
on the answer to our question what
nodejs wants is no J's wants to provide
a purely event
non-blocking infrastructure to script
highly concurrent programs and that's
pretty awesome it's great to have a
sentence where you can kind of sum up
okay this is what this tool wants so
when you ask yourself what should I use
node for if you want to write a program
like this this is the program that node
was designed to Express
and there were a couple other design
goals involved in there but it's awesome
that these design goals were written
down if you actually go to the node.js
github repo at this moment it's really
impossible to find these goals and the
importance of these goals is going to
become a theme throughout this talk so
evented programming is the primary
paradigm for nodejs and so given that
nodejs is so deeply close to javascript
because javascript is fundamentally the
language with Ekman script being respect
underneath we have to ask ourselves ok
so notice a runtime has a really clear
goal but what type of language does
JavaScript want to be now we all know
the story that JavaScript was written in
what 10 days I don't know it's a short
amount of time it was rushed and it was
really just designed so you could have a
little bit of interaction on a website
even after the websites pages had been
loaded in a client so I did some digging
and this is the best I could find on
what type of language javascript wants
to be in the spec it says echo script
syntax is relaxed to enable it to serve
as an easy-to-use scripting language now
this is the best definition of what
JavaScript wants to be that I can find
in the spec and again I do not believe
that the people currently designing the
language are returning to this statement
as they evaluate features moving forward
I don't think I would describe anything
in JavaScript maybe at the moment at
least as relaxed though obviously the
word relaxed can mean many things in
this context so we've talked a little
bit about node in JavaScript and so now
I want to bring up this idea of Russ so
I currently work on Russ now and because
I'm on the core team this is an
incredibly important question to us in
fact we have a repo right now where
we're working on coming up with the
language to answer this question but for
a really long time
we say what type of language distrusts
want to be we've said this rust is a
systems programming language that runs
blazingly fast prevents seg faults and
guarantees thread safety and
unfortunately when most people read this
they hear this and that's a real bummer
because what a language wants to be is
telling people how to use it and so I
asked you at the beginning of this talk
how many people write rust how many
people are interested there were way
more people interested than people
actually writing it and I think it's
because a lot of people are like rust
seems real cool but what do with rust I
I don't know what to write and it's a
good question it's something that we're
actively thinking about and working on
so to go a little back in history rust
was originally designed as a systems
level language with the purpose of
wanting to write something that was
safer and more maintainable than
replacing than C++ which was what
Firefox is currently written in so
Mozilla was like this code it is taking
way too long to develop on we're having
all these bugs we need something that's
safer and more maintainable and by
maintainable they mean I want to be able
to express a safe program without tricks
because tricks are those spots in your
code where the comment is longer than
the code block itself and it's
incredibly brittle and you come back a
day later and you still don't know what
it is that you broke and so what I like
to say with rust is that you know we're
a systems language we're close to the
metal and this is another lovely thing
that almost no one ever really means
there's fun parts of it we're like rust
it's like a fungus that grows on metal
that's how close we are but that still
doesn't really help people use it so a
little bit about rust if you don't know
about it we don't have a runtime we
don't have a garbage collector
we don't have seg faults and we have
static typing and this is what we
generally do to serve that goal purpose
that I just stated and so although Lee
Bailey gave a lovely presentation a bit
back at a Russ comp where they drew
cartoons talking about how Russ works
and this is
the anthropomorphized version of the
compiler a referee that tells you no
because the safest program is one that
does not compile it's true huh but well
that was a pretty aggro looking compiler
I tend to think of the compiler as kind
of my buddy I like programming in rust
because I am constantly pair programming
and this was a small conversation I had
where the Russ compiler helps me
eliminate a whole bunch of the cognitive
overhead I have when I am programming I
can kind of just go in and refactor
something I don't even check my imports
or any of that I'll just type in the
code I want and then run the compiler
and the compiler will be like do this
this and this and it's fantastic we have
error messages where you can often just
cut and paste the suggestion and it
works it's really a great thing and this
is one of the things I love about rust
and so with that I kind of have a
different definition of rust I like to
say rust is a systems programming
language designed to empower all
different types of developers to write
all kinds of fast safe code a lot of
people ask you have a brand-new
programming language all right we have a
bunch of developers who are already
using languages is the idea that you're
trying to convert like say C++
developers to rust and there is an
element of that but rusts real goal is
to take folks who weren't already
systems programmers and make them that
it's additive it's like let's go find
all of the people who weren't being able
to express these types of programs and
let's give them a tool that will let
them do that so part of the way we did
this is through first-class package
management we have this fantastic tool
called cargo cargo is close to my heart
because I came from NPM and cargo learns
a lot of things from NPM and if you're
worried about that trust me we took the
good things and not the bad things
opinions dev tools are full of them but
cargo is fantastic
we have crates io so you can use lots of
libraries and this is a very large cell
over a lot of previous systems
programming languages which don't have
these type of tools to in like make
developer experience much better and so
in 2018 we wrote a road
that and this is something that the
language does every year and it's a to
describe and work with the community to
come up with the goals that we want and
so in 2018 we added this idea of domain
working groups which is kind of to
answer this question well what the heck
should I write in rust we know this is a
problem and so we came up with four
working groups networking services web
assembly CLI apps and embedded devices
and so this has been working well and
it's coming up to our shipping of an
edition in December so the culmination
of all the work of these groups is
coming up really really quick and so
what I want to talk today is about this
idea that rust wants to be a first-class
server-side language now that's kind of
interesting for a systems level language
and so in rust towards our goal of being
able to be a server-side language we
knew that asynchronous features were
going to be incredibly important but
asynchronous features unlike node were
not the foundational value of rust the
real foundational design value of rust
was this idea of memory safety that's
really what we focused on first but with
the growth of the web the pervasiveness
of it with the idea that so many
applications are web based we wanted to
be able to be present there and we
believe that rust would be good about it
remember that one of the biggest
problems that Ryan saw before he
invented node was memory usage and even
in node I know my friends on the node
TSC are like the garbage collector is my
least favorite person oh my gosh they're
constantly fighting memory errors and so
we're like with our memory safety values
we could be a really interesting
language for the server and so we
proceeded to start designing
asynchronous features and so mio is the
foundation of that metal IO this metal
thing comes up all the time it's
incredibly frustrating let's just say
that it's incredibly low level but one
thing to note is that mu is not in our
standard library this is something that
is existing out in the ecosystem and so
mio is the bottom layer and then we have
this idea of futures kind of on the top
and so I like to say futures are
promises but not exactly so if you are
more familiar with promises futures
might be a little bit that's oh there's
a mental model there that you can
and there are a couple of differences
and we are adding some just very small
pieces particularly the types of futures
to the standard library in order to be
able to serve this goal of being a
server-side language and so when you put
futures and neo together fundamentally
our asynchronous paradigm at the moment
is this idea of Tokyo and you'll see
that these all say IO at the end but the
names are like a bit inscrutable and
trying to figure these all out together
can be a bit difficult so you can kind
of understand that Tokyo is when you
take this top-level kind of futures
promises abstraction and put it on top
of this metal IO layer and when we put
those together we get Tokyo and so the
beautiful nodejs system diagram which
was good I decided I love you know
editing things in mspaint and so
revealing to you today the rust system
yeah so this is kind of a haphazard
diagram but the idea here is to try and
talk about the fact that we took a lot
of influence from nodejs when we started
approaching asynchronous language design
and rus and so here you can see we don't
have a runtime but we've got the rust
futures and we have tasks and we have
this idea of the Tokyo reactor now all
of these are very cool but remembering
that rust is a systems level language
that allows you all of this
configuration and really wants you to
have memory safety even though this is
incredibly close to node and when I
endeavour to start writing some
asynchronous rust code which in the long
run will look like this where they sink
in a wait
one thing that's fascinating from my
very first experiment was I wrote a
bunch of asynchronous rust code it
passed the compiler finally it passed
all of the Lintz and I ran the program
and nothing happened it was like let's
know it's rust if it compiles it should
work what's going on
and that is because starting an event
loop an event loop was something that I
fundamentally understood to be just
implicit I'm a node developer it's there
I know the event loop is there but here
in rust it wasn't it turns out that the
one step I had missed was actually
starting an event
and so that's an interesting thing and
we realized and one of the biggest
frustrating parts of our see a
synchronous story and rest is so many
people come to rust with different ideas
of asynchronous program expression we
all are bringing different things to the
table and so creating an ergonomic
experience for everyone is incredibly
difficult so that's a bunch to say about
rust and it wanting to do some
asynchronous stuff but I have another
question this first thing everyone was
like yeah of course first wants to be a
first class server-side language but I
want to ask should it that's a really
interesting question is this why would
rust want why should be writing web
services in rust and that's kind of
questions like a system's level language
should we really be writing a web
service in that like should you write a
web service with a language that was
designed to write a browser
no no it's interesting so as I said
before russ was originally designed to
replace C++ in Firefox here and there's
kind of an interesting illusion here
like a systems level programming
language usually the first thing you
think to write in a systems level
language is an operating system and what
are browsers if not kind of their own
type of operating system and so Firefox
quantum shift of the 1st of kind
paralyzed style system stylo last year
and it was incredibly successful use
Firefox it's great and fundamentally
this was because rust rust has this
ability to be incredibly maintainable
and it's incredibly expressive so these
are some cartoons from Julia Evans and
if you love code cartoons you should
check hers out this is a incredibly not
scientific diagram of your program
working nests
but the idea here is that rust makes
improbable programs possible right and
the idea is that it's empowering and so
why should we take this type of power
away from people who are looking to
write web services I think there's a
whole bunch of web services that have
yet to be written and it's because
there's not yet been a language to be
able to express them so and again this
whole idea of empowering for wide
variety of people who might not
otherwise consider themselves systems
programmers I want web developers to be
systems programmers and so does rust and
so the fundamental answer to this
question is yes I do I do absolutely
think that you should do this and so
does rust and fundamentally this comes
down to these ideas of memory I think
that as we have lots of conversations
about web development we tend to have a
lot of conversations about both
concurrency and memory and rust has this
idea of finding contradictions and
saying no I don't I don't believe that
is a fundamental trade-off I think that
we can write a language that allows you
to do all three of these things you
don't have to pick just two now here's
the trick though the real trick here is
productivity productivity is incredibly
difficult concept and it comes down to
developer experience have you had this
developer experience I have huh so to
jump into something that seems like it's
completely different
to quote douglas adams the history of
every major galactic civilization tends
to pass through three distinct and
recognizable phases those of survival
inquiry and sophistication otherwise
known as the how the why and the we're
face is for instance the first phrase is
characterized by the question how can we
eat the second why do we eat and the
third where shall we have lunch all
right so now why am I talking about
lunch and Douglas Adams right now and
it's because beard have tits realized
that while programming languages are
historical the people who are using them
are also historical and so people who
are using our programming languages go
through stages of learning and it turns
out that law as we design concepts and
syntax for them these are incredibly
important and so this is from a paper by
Terence Tao who's actually a
mathematician and he defines three
stages of learning the pre rigorous
where you kind of blindly apply
formalism and you're very intuitive kind
of feeling around in a dark room the
second is quite different from that it's
incredibly rigorous where you kind of
have this intense proper application of
formalism like yes I will do this and I
know these are the rules and then
finally this idea of sophistication or
the post rigorous is when we kind of
return
to intuition greatly informed by the
idea of formalism we can return back to
our mental models and less of the strict
specifications of the language itself
and so my friend Dave Herman coined read
this and he pointed a Strauss trips rule
which is that four new features new
programming concepts people insist on
loud explicit syntax whereas four
established features people want
incredibly terse notification and so you
can kind of understand that maybe the
beginner or even the advanced person in
our previous stages of learning like the
loud explicit syntax whereas the people
in the middle sort of like this terse
notation they already know the
formalisms and they just want to apply
them as quickly as possible there are
the people who really count the number
of letters you have to type which is a
whole other thing but an example of this
in rust is how we do error handling so
in rust we do not have exceptions we
have explicit error types and you can
kind of see how we progressed through so
at first you can see here we have a
match on a result type or either it's
okay or you pass an error but that sure
is a lot of codes right for this and
then so after a while we baited a little
bit tercer and we had this try macro you
can see the word try with the
exclamation point and it turns out that
even those four characters were like a
little bit too much we're like this is
error handling we all get it let's just
get on with it and so now we have this
postfix operator called the question
mark which maybe you didn't even see
because it's so not loud and that just
propagates an error up to the function
that calls it and so this is an example
of us building syntax for this now it
would have been incredibly difficult to
have introduced question mark first we
couldn't have just released rust with
question mark there is nobody who was
ready for it at that point but as people
moved from the beginning stages to that
intermediate stage their desire for how
loud the language should be and how loud
the syntax should be changed and so this
is one way that we have kind of
historical recursive naswinger design
process and so this comes under this
idea of the mechanism is not the model
and so Dave Herman writes I see this a
lot in
and design as we spend more and more of
our time swimming in formalisms like
specs semantics or implementations it's
easier for us to overlook these fuzzier
intuitions just like in mathematics
rigorous tools like specs help us be
precise but the mechanism of our designs
and a developer's mental model they
support are two separate things and
often times and this fall goes back to
Simon Paton Jones keynote yesterday we
focused so much on the technology and
not the ideas and I think we're in an
era of language design at least in very
popular language design that we're
losing track of these ideas and
intuitions so interestingly enough rust
has taken this kind of to the nth degree
where we tend to build features for the
survival and sophistication stages we
really are focusing on our ganache ideas
on these ideas of developer intuitions
and yeah this makes the folks in the
inquiry stage like incredibly frustrated
and you'll see very soon I'm gonna show
some examples of our github
conversations but they are wrong no
press doesn't have all the answers but
one of the things that we are trying to
do with language design in rust is we're
trying our best to ask the right
questions like and so fundamentally the
real question for us is can rust achieve
the ergonomics and productivity required
to make systems level control viable for
web development web development is
hallmarked by these languages that tend
to be higher level scripting languages
that have high abstractions it's very
easy to be productive in them can Russ
do that while also giving you that
systems level control it's an open
question and it's the question that will
determine the success of rust I believe
and so are we doing it I don't know just
a stack overflow
we have been the most loved programming
language for three years I don't know
what that means does anybody know what
that means but one of the things that I
do think is actually a good example of
us attempting to succeed is this article
by Nick Fitzgerald called oxidizing
source maps with rust and webassembly
where he demonstrates that writing a
source Maps implementation in rust and
then compiling it to web assembly was
not only significantly faster than the
JavaScript but it was also more
consistent
like that jump in speed I think is way
less important than that lack of spread
look at that consistency in what you can
expect and that's super awesome and it's
incredibly successful
now of course M Ralph who also spoke out
from at the conference yesterday
immediately it was like you don't need
rust and webassembly to speed up your
JavaScript you don't need to and he
proceeded to give an absolutely
fascinating discussion of v8 internals
and writing JavaScript with all the
tricks to make things go incredibly fast
and I love blog posts like this but I
think he missed the point of what rust
wants to do and so Nick actually
followed up with incredibly a like
polite blog post but it was called speed
without wizardry and in it he says the
oxidizing article recounts my experience
integrating rust compiled to web
assembly into the source map JavaScript
library although the JavaScript
implementation was originally authored
in idiomatic JavaScript style as we
profile and implemented speed
improvements the code became hard to
read and maintain however with rust and
at zero cost abstractions we found that
there was no trade-off between
performance and clean code and so that's
the ideas like of course I mean you can
be fast but being fast and being able to
remain maintainable is incredibly
important and so the question is how did
rust get to this point what is Russ
trying to do and what were the processes
that helped us lead to this design and
so there's a beautiful talk called why
wasn't I consulted how rust is open
source software by niko mysticus and
Eric Turin who are on the core team with
me and this is the core team and we have
tons more people who have earned 100
people working on rust right now and it
comes down to this idea of why wasn't I
consulted and Paul Ford wrote an essay
on this and says why wasn't I consulted
is the fundamental question of the web
it is the rule for which other rules are
derived humans have a fundamental need
to be consulted engaged and to exercise
their knowledge and thus power and no
other medium that came before has been
able to tap into that as effectively and
so when we do consultation Russ style we
are doing everything the
an RFC every major decision and we
consider most things major decisions
even policy decisions and even people
from the core team have to write an RFC
to get something into the language and
so we drive it through to a steady state
of consensus and we absolutely insist
that all decisions rest on prior public
debate there's no going off into a room
and then going back to the thread and
saying we figured it out we have to hash
it out on that issue and this is
actually incredibly radical and reading
I always read this quote and I'm like I
can't even believe this is true but the
Apache Software Foundation has a very
different idea about how to do this
language design they say the users thing
called lazy consensus and lazy consensus
is this it means that when you are
convinced that you know what the
community would like to see happen
you can simply assume that you already
have consensus and get on with the work
all right all right so we disagree with
that I still can't believe that's real
and so a lot of that has to do with this
idea of articulating visions and with
the whole idea is this idea of thought
leadership and particularly if you've
been in JavaScript for a while there's
tons of discussion of thought leadership
but there's not maybe a lot of actual
thought leadership happening the idea is
that you need to expose a way of
thinking and inspire communities towards
a clear goal the whole point of getting
everyone together is that we have shared
values and making these language
decisions is a lot easier when we all
share similar values and in doing this
we can help identify and explain
historical themes and so I'm not going
to quote who this was from but I like
the idea that every good work of
software starts by scratching a
developer's personal itch and the whole
goal of our method is to make everybody
each the same way because that doesn't
sound weird you know what I mean
but yeah vision values happen at a lot
of different scales and having a road
map process and thus a vision makes it a
lot easier to say no and saying note is
incredibly incredibly important now you
might be saying actually all of this
like kumbaya stuff you're talking about
like
pluralism that's like great but like
doesn't that like kind of really stink
like how do you get anything done
so this is our RFC's repo check this a
little bit a while ago and you can see
the number of comments there these
aren't too bad but asynchronous features
were really interesting because people
really cared about this this
asynchronous features are incredibly
important and so you can see the numbers
start going up a lot higher and here
even higher just as an aside github like
reactions are not votes no one votes in
rust and this is a huge misconception of
the crew but yeah lots and lots of
comments and so we have problems of
scale
RFC threads can get a hundred civil
insightful comments in 24 hours that's
after you eliminate all the like weird
craft that every issue gets and so
there's an information overload and as
many people might not actually realize
open source you think Oh language design
you need a lot of technical people know
we desperately need managers oh my gosh
we need managers to be able to handle
all of these people and that's because
fundamentally we believe all of these
people are what is making us make a
better language we genuinely believe
that pluralism is what is going to lead
to actually better design and we've seen
this happen multiple times and so what's
the point of me saying all of this right
so I think fundamentally that rust
especially it's a synchronous story
would be would not be the same if it
weren't for node right rust is in part
at least a reaction to note a node exist
for a very specific reason and it was a
response to the historical and material
situation it was written in however I
think that there are ways that noted
JavaScript can also respond to rust
because node in JavaScript as I
mentioned to y'all before has not really
hated their goals or audience in a long
time
I have dug for this information I found
one private repo that had one readme
commit with nothing in it there's a lack
of vision here and this lack of vision
can have some serious problems like we
are working incredibly hard in open
source but to what end and
for who and this black of vision can
cause a mismatch in expectations and I'm
running out of time so I'll skip forward
to this but I want to talk about the
worst implications of a lack of vision
and so we've talked about this man
before
beyond strauss trop the creator of c++
and he recently wrote an incredibly
important article and in it he said many
most people in working group 21 are
working independently towards non shared
goals individually many maybe even most
proposals make sense together they are
obviously he's not terribly inclusive
insanity probably means ridiculous to
the point of endangering the future of
C++ and the title of his article was
remember the vasa
and so I will leave you with this story
the vasa was a Swedish galleon which is
a fancy word for ship one of the largest
and most heavily armed warships of its
time at the beginning of its maiden
voyage in 1628 the Vasa sank after only
about 1300 metres driving distance in
normal swell due to serious structural
instability and this is because the Vasa
was supposed to be the Swedish ship that
a bunch of people built incredibly
intuitively if they could find a spot
for an extra gun or an extra something
they were just tacking it on there just
you could think of it as feature creep
out of control and so in the article
yarn says we need a reasonably coherent
language that can be used by ordinary
programmers whose main concern is to
ship great applications on time
that's the productivity bit right there
all right so he switches metaphors I
don't know why but we have now about a
hundred and fifty cooks that is not a
good way to get a tasty and balanced
meal so 150 shipbuilders not a very good
ship and so he says we are on the path
to something that could destroy C++ we
must get off this path and so this is
the idea that without shared vision we
can end up with languages that are the
vasa all right and so here's a map this
is about how far it went and I think we
all believe that we want our languages
to get a little bit farther than this
so I ergonomics and productivity are the
determinants by which the success of any
programming language will
measured and in order to get those right
we need our users to be in the room and
so Russ Cox said this about go but I
think it's really useful for all
languages to make go successful we need
everyone's help and everyone isn't here
and in Brust we're trying our best we
want everyone to be there alright and so
we return to this idea of the best first
programming language and in that article
that had that ridiculous diagram they
said the major problem caused by the
unavailability of feature uniformity and
that future uniformity means like one
way to express one thing is that the
size of the language increases which in
turn results in a longer learning curve
this leads to an increase in the
language complexity in terms of the
number and type of constructs
resultantly a language without feature
uniformity usually demands an instructor
to teach a subset of the language a
programmer could use that subset to
write code but for reading code
comprehensive knowledge is required and
so this is my final statement here I'm a
little sad that JavaScript is becoming
not a great first programming language
and more importantly I believe that and
I'm genuinely sad because I think if
it's true it likely happened by accident
I don't think it happened on purpose I
think this is happening and continues to
happen by accident as a lack of shared
vision and so we had that original
relaxed easy to use scripting language
vision but we haven't returned to it and
when I was first reading the spec I was
giving a talk called if you wish to
learn es6 from scratch you must first
invent the universe and I said this
because I genuinely believe this to be
true and now I'm genuinely afraid that
that is going away and so I'll leave you
with this I'd like to see all languages
community language communities better
articulate their visions and I'd like to
see more requests for feedback get more
people involved all right and I'd also
like to see a greater visual realization
that the artifacts we build are
historical artifacts these things are
products of their time and a
that is certainly going to change and so
it's incredibly important to keep the
feedback loop between the designers and
the people using the language incredibly
small and this is not fun you saw those
comments on github the involving lots of
people is incredibly hard and it gets
really uncomfortable and you feel like
you're maybe not moving as fast as you
could if you could just assume what
everyone wanted but the technology we
build is not the product of rationally
inevitable trends you're not going to
figure this out in your head by using
some sort of proof or theorem alright it
is the result of contingent turns of
history which means you have to go out
into the world and find out what that
history is and history is going to move
forward and we need to pray prioritizing
the work of understanding that history
and I genuinely believe that we are not
so I am excited though because it's the
type of work I love to do and it is the
work to be done and I hope more folks
join us thanks
[Applause]